[Musique]
c'est moche on peut monter jusqu'à 200 m
l obélisque de washington à mesure que
169 m en somme ça qui montra le plus
haut je vous écris je savais faire on va
penser l'exposition universelle je vais
pas recommencer je vois pas l'intérêt de
construire un machin qui sert à rien qui
va falloir démonter juste après vous
avait réponse à tout la vie m'a appris à
me méfier des surprises
[Musique]
sa
carte pour j'espérais ne jamais vous
[Musique]
fait rabat pour y avoir des idées sur le
sujet du concours il faut voir plus
libre
plus audacieux
une tour
300 mètres
entièrement en métal
un défi à la gravité
aux éléments
cette tour messieurs
c'est paris
son rayonnement
classement
pourquoi tu m'as pas tout dit
lui même je te parle pas d'amour
je te parle de réputation
voyez trop grand trop au pari est contre
nous 100 m a raconté levan demeure que
la trouve à faire assez grande
[Applaudissements]
et les scandales dire quand c'est un
scandale
que nous allons entreprendre personne ne
l'a jamais tenté nous allons construire
cette tour les gars c'est celle de la
france
c'est surtout la vôtre jaloux c'est
ensemble qu'on a commencé c'est ensemble
qu'on va l'achever
ab1
[Musique]